ever since vulture published a 2022
article that produced several
allegations from cast and crew members
of Buffy the Vampire Slayer Angel
dollhouse and Justice League the Firefly
creator has been keeping a much lower
profile while Weeden wasn't the only
filmmaker associated with firefly he is
the creator of the franchise and
responsible for writing several episodes
as well as the film in an interview on
the inside of you podcast Nathan fillian
noted that it would be heartbreaking if
Firefly continued without its creator
regarding the previously mentioned
allegations billian said that was not my
experience with that man I would work
with Jos again in a second